federal authorities are investigating a
threat against the u.s
capitol that was broadcast over radio
frequencies used by
pilots it may have been designed to
suggest attacking the building today
as congress counts the electoral college
votes the message
obtained exclusively by cbs news said
the attack
would avenge iranian general qasim
solomani
cbs news senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge
has our report
that threat against the capital was
heard by multiple air traffic
controllers in new york monday
those sources tell cbs news the
government does not believe
it's credible it came one day after
crowds gathered in iraq to mark the
anniversary of general qasim sulaimani's
death
the u.s military executed a flawless
precision strike
that killed solomani and terminated his
evil reign of terror forever
last year's strike launched days of
mourning anti-american protests
and iranian counter-strikes that
targeted two u.s military bases in iraq
inflicting damage but no deaths
sulaimani was a revered figure in iran
and among its allies that nation's
parliament designated the u.s
military and pentagon as terrorist
organizations
following his death in reference to the
anniversary secretary of state mike
pompeo said tuesday
the u.s is on guard and always ready to
deter
iranian attacks as for the digitized
voice recording
sources tell cbs news the pentagon and
other agencies have been briefed
the faa says it's working with law
enforcement and the fbi
is not commenting for cbs this morning
i'm katherine herridge in washington